-Let's get to the news.
Republicans announced last night
that the latest
GOP health-care plan
will not be moving forward,
making this the second draft of
the bill to fail in the Senate.
Though when it comes
to President Trump,
the third time's the charm.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
It's the second draft
of the Republican health-care
bill to fail in the Senate.
"What's a second draft?"
asked the writer
of "Transformers."
[ Laughter ]
According to Politico,
the news that two additional
Republican senators
were not supporting
the GOP health-care plan
came as a surprise
to President Trump.
And if there's one thing
President Trump hates,
it's Eric.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
After the failure of
the GOP health-care plan,
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
outlined plans
to repeal Obamacare
without a bill to replace it,
the same way we got rid of Obama
without a good plan
to replace him.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Have it laid out in advance.
Following news that the Senate
health-care plan will not pass,
President Trump said
that it is important
to get more Republicans
into office.
More?
Pretty sure when
the Titanic was sinking,
the answer wasn't more icebergs.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
According...
According to reports,
the eighth person
who was present at the meeting
between Donald Trump Jr.
and a Russian lawyer
has been identified,
and you're not going to
believe who it was.
[ Laughter ]
Double Gumps.
According to
a new Bloomberg poll,
people view President Trump
more favorably
than Hillary Clinton.
Said one voter,
"He just seems more fun."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
According to reports, the actor
who voices Kermit the Frog
was fired by Disney
for his repeated unacceptable
business conduct.
Apparently --
and this is pretty shocking --
he put his hand
up a coworker's butt.
[ Laughter ]
Not Kermit's.
A woman in China was recently
stopped by customs officials
for trying to sneak
over 100 iPhones
from Hong Kong to mainland China
by strapping them to her body.
She would've
gotten away with it,
but then someone said,
"Hey, Siri,"
and a hundred voices
said, "Yes?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
A 97 -- A 97-year-old
Philadelphia man
who left high school early
to fight in World War II
received his diploma
this weekend.
And his parents
didn't even show up!
[ Laughter ]
That's better.
Don't want a couple
of 125-year-olds
sitting through graduation.
[ Wheezes ]
"Is that him?!"
[ Laughs ]
[ Applause ]
Today was
National Sour Candy Day.
Either that, or that's just what
Mike Pence's face looks like.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And finally,
the NYPD is searching
for a person who stole
a 100-year-old tortoise
from an animal shelter.
The ancient tortoise
was last seen
failing to pass
a new health-care bill.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"We tried very hard.
We tried very, very hard."
Ladies and gentlemen, we got
a great show for you tonight!